the A to Z of isms young isn't you
definitely have heard of ageism or what
about young ISM our young people
discriminated against in the same way
old people often are it's hard to get my
stats on this and it's not a designated
subject in sociology or economics but
look closely and you'll see it all
around us I felt it and experienced it
on a personal level and stole as many of
my friends when I started my first job I
was told by a colleague that young
people don't know what real hard work
looks like I was judged negatively
before I've even done any work even when
I used to go into a shop having signs
that say only to school children at a
time felt like a slap in the face we
would lever and our signs that say that
about old people so why is it justified
when it comes to young people and then
there's young ISM at a societal level
young people are treated differently
because of their age they aren't given
the same political rights and
opportunities arose while no one is
suggesting that babies should be heading
to the polls many do you believe that 16
and 17-year olds should have the right
to vote as they now do in Scotland young
people also treated unfairly in the
workplace the minimum wage for young
people is lower than adults which means
young people get paid less to drink the
exact same job is that fair even in
school which is designed to help and
nurture young people they still often
aren't treated with respect all taken
seriously young people get no real say
over their curriculum
schools aren't designed to empower them
they are given little practical advice
to prepare them for adulthood we can't
expect someone to suddenly become an
active citizen when they become an adult
that process must start much earlier
young people are our future but need to
have the power to change their present
if we want to create a better world
young people have always played a
significant role in shaping society from
the edelweiss Pirates who opposed Hitler
in the 30s to the March for our life
protest against gun violence there is a
history of young people pushing to
create change and fight for the rights
of people across the world not just in
their own communities young people today
are growing up knowing the climate
Changez going to threaten our world they
are likely to never buy their own home
and if they go to university they're
going to leave with tens of thousands of
pounds of debt without any guaranteed
job it's young people who are going to
have to solve the biggest issues we face
today all while facing these challenges
it's no wonder there's a huge mental
health crisis we need to treat young
people with the respect they deserve
because if we don't everyone loses out
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon